And I would also like to add that
even though the Sydney funnel webs are quite venomous
and people do die from Sydney funnel webs,
the Sydney fireworks fighter is not aggressive by nature.
So you have to provoke one of them pretty badly
or like
frighten one pretty badly for it to bite you with its stabby
little fangs. Whereas I feel like men are just more of a mixed bag
like some of them are aggressive by nature and you don't know
like their behaviour can be quite unpredictable.
Um, you usually don't have to provoke them at all for them to show um
aggression or some sort of violence or harassment towards you.
And I had two of these spiders
watching me shower every single day for about 3 months
and they never made a move,
not once.
And I'm sorry but I just can't say that about a single man that I know.
And the other thing about them is that
while their bite can be extremely painful,
it's quite unlikely that I'm going to need 10 years of therapy
to recover from a Sydney funnel web spider
which is more than I can say about my ex boyfriend.
And if I got bitten by a Sydney funnel web,
while I might need surgery to cover up the appearance of the scar
as well as a lot of medical treatment,
that medical treatment would be covered by Medicare,
which is Australia's public healthcare system.
This is Unlike other issues that are not covered by Medicare,
such as psychologists
to deal with the trauma of sexual violence from a man,
birth control,
which women are expected to look after majority of the time
to basically cope with the ongoing threat that it poses
to get pregnant to a man
and then be tied to that man for the rest of your life,
especially if that man is abusive.
Alternative healthcare remedies for um things like vaginismus,
um chronic thrush
and endometriosis that are triggered by sexual violence
and gynecological appointments
which are extremely expensive
and usually you have to pay $250
just for a man to tell you that your pain is imagined
but just like men,
all Sydney funnel webs should be treated as potentially dangerous.
However, unlike men,
only 10 to 15 percent of their bikes are actually venomous
whereas we know that majority of men have perpetrated sexual violence
or sexual harassment or coercive control
or gaslighting on a woman at some point in their lives
unlike Sydney funnel web spiders,
the other important point to note is that um,
Sydney funnel web spiders
can actually just be eradicated with a can of really strong
bug spray that you can buy from your local supermarket
whereas it is much harder to eradicate a man from your life
once he's decided to sink his little fangs into you and destroy you.
It's gonna cost a lot more than 1299.
It might cost you your life
Or it might cost you years and years of money in therapy
and trauma counseling.
It might cost you your sense of safety or security.
And even if you do try to spray them away,
there's no guarantee that they won't come back to haunt you.
Or at least, you know,
a spider's not gonna go around and tell everyone in its Social Circle
that you're a crazy ex girlfriend.